que c'est demain que débute la formation
des 10000 futur préposés aux
bénéficiaires formation en accéléré on
veut permettre à des milliers de
personnes de venir en renfort
aussitôt que possible en septembre dont
les 6 h et celle des les résidences pour
aînés surtout dans l'éventualité d'une
deuxième vague de covè 19 avec nous ils
vont riendeau gérontologue sociale et
chargé de cours en gérontologie sociale
à l'uqam syrien de bonjour bonjour vous
allez vous mettre donner cette formation
en montérégie
dès cette semaine mais ce que veut nous
parler un peu du contenu de la formation
pour les futurs préposé en fait la
formation comme tel le porte le site de
natation d'études professionnelles et
une formation de 375 harkis comme vous
l'avez mentionné si bien vous êtes en
mode accéléré à la commission scolaire
des grandes seigneuries a effectivement
permis les autres comme ce cas là nous
avons l'opportunité et la chance
d'offrir ce programme nous avons eu par
contre le plan de travail du programme
tout dernièrement à savoir cette semaine
et affectivement yogi huit compétences
qui sont amalgamés l'une à la suite de
l'autre évidemment et des compétences en
laboratoire en classe tu ailles et aussi
des compétences à distance
et puis effectivement il va y avoir une
période le in vivo en milieu de longue
durée pour qu'effectivement les gens
puissent se prête ce qui si l'on a
forcément à prendre dans le volet
théorique est aussi l'envolée eux à
distance
donc si je comprends dit tout se fait
très vite là autant la formation pour
les préposés mais les formateurs comme
vous vous devez vous préparer très
rapidement à meilhan le le plan de court
comme ça quelques jours avant de
commencer ce que vous estimez quand même
que vous êtes prêts à donner la
formation s'est dit totalement pour une
raison tout à fait à mon avis en arabe
si l'expérience sensible concernant
d'autres en trois ans de formation
privés aux bénéficiaires elle avait par
des formateurs à travers le québec ont
une expérience une expertise extrêmement
et l'ufisc va faciliter les choses parce
que nous sommes habitués à briller entre
guillemets avec son de conditions bien
sous pression alors on a reçu très
agréablement et savoir humblement de
programme
nous sommes d'ailleurs est aujourd'hui
et demain et dans les journées qui vont
suivre en implantation et en six mois je
suis très confiant évidemment
ce programme devra y soit ta ble ment
être éphémère dans le temps savoir il ya
10000 quand vous l'avez bien mentionné
personnes qui vont arriver à bon port on
le souhaite et par la suite bon le des
ep 2 870 heures lui reprend le collier
dès l'automne est encore là bien
évidemment parce que le développer pour
les propos de bénéfices elle n'est pas
que pour les préposés aux bénéficiaires
est également aussi pour les auxiliaires
ou services de santé et sociaux qu'on
appelle et a3 est en selle et c'est donc
ce que j'ai appelé lors la même façon le
réel des ep 800 soldats hillary il amène
à plusieurs titres dans faut alors que
celui-ci oui vous il est très
circonscrits d'un vin délimité comme
vous l'avez mentionné pour arriver à
former rapidement bon puis cette
formation là comment ce demain alors que
ce sera une journée consacrée à contre
la maltraitance des aînés 1 journée
thématique demain et vous de votre côté
je sais que vous mettez beaucoup pour
une charte de la bientraitance à
l'endroit des aînés
parlez nous un peu de cette charte est
là en fait vous êtes gentils de
m'approprier plus voler ce haut fait
sonner pour moi comme tel qui a
introduit une charge ou donner
rapidement
il a même si on est heureux on se
projette dans la région de rester une
charte de la bientraitance qui a été
mise de l'avant
il ya deux ans entre autres avec la
table de concertation entre magog pour
la grande région de l'exp voyez-vous et
ses jalons ont fait un travail
extraordinaire
j'ai eu le privilège de faire les
conférence d'ouverture français anglais
pour lancer cette chasse s'il y avait un
souhait c'est qu'elle devienne pas un
québécois âgé que chacune des régions
administratives qu est ce qu une des
villes finalement et à merci puisse
aller de l'avant
vivre avec une charte de bientraitance
très longtemps nous avons parlé comme
vous le savez même la croix de
maltraitance qui est une traduction
libre de rôles de revioo par la suite ça
sert et signer avec la bientraitance qui
a commencé à prendre de l'espace
on ne quitte pas malheureusement des
thématiques importantes comme l'âgisme
l'intimidation la maltraitance
proprement dite mais il ya comme un
nouveau courant un peu paradigme halles
qui nous installe présentement avec le
volet de bientraitance et c'est très
souhaitable d'avoir un parfum de
bientraitance et de promouvoir cette
bientraitance à la une charte
il faut encore félicitations aux gens de
la région de l'esprit humain
alors qui est symbolique mais qui était
signée par les dignitaires l est pas et
qui ont été aussi bien lancée elle fait
son petit chemin est effectivement
aujourd'hui on pourrait qualifier cette
charte est enfin prise
une brise publiques gouvernementales
évidemment locales et provinciales
surtout au sortir de deux cette vague de
covè 19 ans qui a exacerbé aussi
certains des phénomènes que vous avez
identifié
vous savez là à l'uqam la gérontologie
sociale s'intéresse beaucoup à la
personne âgée forcément dans sa société
et dans l'ensemble des 6000 10,2 soit le
milieu résidentiel le milieu du hlm le
milieu résidences pour aînés est
évidemment les sièges celle des donc la
grande visibilité sans être opportuniste
la grande visibilité de la gérontologie
la gériatrie pas permis depuis les
derniers mois je pense de sensibiliser
la population québécoise à toute une
série de réflexions d'actions dans le
cadre de bientraitance évidemment est
aussi un cadre du respect de la dignité
de nous aimer le pré ministre monsieur
le guen a parlé à maintes et maintes
reprises donc sur cette même foule et
j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans un beau
tourner à gérontologie gerontology
hattrick présentement au québec
le mieux est à venir au niveau de la
réflexion madame blais avec les maisons
des années fait état aussi de projets
qui vont avoir un bon levier
moi je pense maintenant une très belle
courbe de madame lacroix donc après
cette crise dans les ch à celle dévoilée
cette opportunité donc de faire valoir
tout ça est de parler de bien traitance
chez les aînés n'ont rien de
gérontologue social merci beaucoup merci
merci